[Música]
en un intento por levantar la economía
del país y terminar con el
desabastecimiento el gobierno de cuba
hizo hace unos días un anuncio que tal
vez décadas atrás sería completamente
impensable para este país socialista las
autoridades permitieron la operación de
empresas mixtas de capital extranjero en
el comercio minorista el gobierno
también anunció que va a permitir las
empresas completamente privadas para los
mayoristas la medida sorprende y también
representa un giro en la fuertemente
centralizada economía cubana que es
manejada enteramente por el estado desde
la ciudad de la habana pero desde el
gobierno han sido muy claros en advertir
que flexibilizar no significa
necesariamente el abandono del modelo
socialista está el sistema mostrando
síntomas de una necesidad urgente de
reformas o nuestra o muestra también
síntomas de un agotamiento ya después de
seis décadas de haber sido instaurado
que tanto está la apertura respondiendo
a las necesidades urgentes del sistema o
está respondiendo a las necesidades
de integrar a cuba en la realidad
mundial a través del comercio y
modernizarse un poco este país veamos
las declaraciones de la viceministra
primera de comercio exterior ana
teresita gonzález fraga
se ha decidido promover en el desarrollo
en promover el desarrollo en todo el
país de negocios para impulsar el
comercio mayorista a través de la
inversión extranjera aquí se van a dar
detalles también de los modelos de
negocio a utilizar pero yo creo que es
importante que se conozca que la
inversión extranjera hasta hoy la hemos
dedicado básicamente para producir
bienes y servicios y hoy realmente nos
estamos proponiendo que se cree en
entidades de inversión extranjera para
comercializar en el mercado mayorista
nosotros buscamos que estas medidas
tengan una incidencia inmediata en los
problemas de desabastecimiento y que
contribuyan también a mejorar la la
oferta que existe hoy en la tienda de
moneda libremente convertibles y en
moneda nacional varias empresas de
diferentes países han mostrado interés
en ingresar al mercado cubano que
resulta que es un mercado bastante
atractivo para algunos sectores
específicos pero tanto empresas como
algunos gobiernos han mostrado
nada un requerimiento de forma unificada
y son garantías garantías jurídicas
queda entonces la pregunta qué garantías
está dando el gobierno cubano a quienes
decidan invertir en cuba en el mercado
minorista y mayorista esta cuba en
condiciones de dar inicio a una
transformación de su modelo socialista y
establecer un modelo en un nuevo
capítulo llamémoslo de alguna manera
como el socialismo con características
cubanas tomando un poco el ejemplo de
países como china laos vietnam todos
gobernados por comunistas pero con
economías centralizadas pero que han
hecho una apertura de sus economías en
el caso de china y de vietnam les ha
ayudado a tener un fuerte músculo
económico para poder ser competitivos a
nivel internacional
cuba ha dado pasos en esta apertura
pasos que han sido lentos y cuyos
efectos tal parece que todavía no se ven
reflejados en el bienestar de la
población y tampoco pues hay un músculo
económico que le permita ser muy
competitivos a nivel internacional
porque las reformas buscan es
diversificar la oferta a la población es
decir el mercado interno y con a la
recuperación de la industria nacional en
algunos casos muy afectada por la
decisión de preferir importar productos
en vez de producir este nuevo capítulo
de apertura cubana a la inversión
extranjera para el mercado minorista y
mayorista es nuestro tema de análisis
hoy en france 24 para analizar este tema
está con nosotros paula jiménez ella es
psicóloga magister investigadora y
analista del centro latinoamericano de
análisis estratégico es también
integrante de la red de intelectuales de
defensa de la humanidad ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de buenos aires
en la capital argentina y en la ciudad
de west palm beach en el estado de
florida en los estados unidos está el
señor luis enrique ferrer ex preso
político y de conciencia de la primera
negra de cuba es miembro de la unión
patriótica de cuba les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram en
facebook en donde no se encuentran como
france24 bajo ese anti logo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate de fe 24 en youtube también
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
y participar en el chat en vivo y
también saluda a las personas que nos
están escuchando en nuestro podcast
todos los contenidos del programa los
pueden encontrar en diferentes
plataformas estamos en app el podcast en
spotify deezer y en junin
antes de comenzar el programa quiero
hacer la aclaración y decir que el
departamento de producción de invitados
de france24 intentó contactar a alguien
que fuera fuente oficial del gobierno
cubano para participar en este programa
para conocer y analizar más puntos a
profundidad sobre este tema pero no
obtuvimos respuesta hasta el momento por
lo tanto pues vamos a direccionar el
programa en ese sentido sin tener una
fuente oficial pero haciendo el análisis
con nuestros invitados saludo entonces a
paula en la ciudad de buenos aires- y le
doy la bienvenida del programa paula
gracias por estar con nosotros punto de
partida esta apertura y esta apertura a
la inversión extranjera en el mercado
minorista y mayorista en cuba' muestra
síntomas urgentes de este sistema por
unas reformas o por unas fisuras que
poco a poco se están abriendo más
qué tal santiago os gusta saludarte un
saludo también para luis y para toda la
audiencia que esté escuchando las 24
bueno fundamentalmente creo que es
necesario analizar el contexto donde la
crisis por pandemia ha dejado a la
mayoría de los países del mundo no
importa cuál es el sistema en bajo el
cual ejerza del gobierno e incluso los
mismos estados unidos por niveles de
inflación
altísimos con niveles de desigualdad que
se incrementaron enormemente
entonces en el marco estructural esta es
la realidad un mundo en crisis donde los
gobiernos están teniendo que salir a
sostener a inventar ya encontrar de
manera resiliente salidas para esta
situación que pone en evidencia la
crisis estructural del sistema
capitalista entonces en ese sentido creo
que está está inversión extranjera que
hace el gobierno por parte del gobierno
de cuba tiene que ver con este contexto
me decían algunos compañeros de
fuente cubana de cubanos y cubanas de
allí que no es la primera vez que
también en el período especial hugo
inversión extranjera y que obviamente es
una de las herramientas que se utiliza
dentro de la planificación de políticas
para llevar adelante algún tipo de
desarrollo en este caso y también como
respuesta a las demandas que se hicieron
que se dejaron ver en la calle en la
calle de la habana de los distintos
lugares de cuba en relación a la
situación de crisis obviamente estas
inversiones extranjeras vienen a dar
respuesta a esta esta crisis que se está
viviendo en el país socialista y lo
importante para analizar es que estas
inversiones extranjeras mientras sean
dentro de la economía planificada que
lleva adelante cuba mientras no sea
libre mercado lo que se lleva adelante
mientras haya un control de los
monopolios como siempre ha habido en
cuba y se ponga como prioridad como
siempre se ocupa el bienestar del
ciudadano
y que haya inversiones que sean
sustentables y no especulativas no me
parece tiene ese punto
problema de las inversiones para
resolver esta crisis
la primera vez que cuba lo hace ya lo
hemos visto en la inversión como lo
decía la
viceministra primera en hubo una
inversión extranjera en un área muy
específica que fue en términos de la
oferta de servicios los grandes hoteles
son cadenas hoteleras internacionales
que ofrecen servicios para esta
industria que es el pilar fundamental de
la economía cubana esta sería la primera
vez que entran a hacer inversión en este
sector específico hacia la aclaración en
el minorista y en el mayorista pero cuba
en cierta forma haya estado abierto a la
inversión extranjera en diferentes
episodios de su historia reciente pasó
entonces ahora saludar a luis enrique él
se encuentra en el sur del estado de la
florida luis enrique gracias por estar
con nosotros y punto de partida es la
misma pregunta para los dos invitados
para conocer posiciones esta apertura la
inversión extranjera para estos dos
tipos de mercados distintos que
representa una decisión apresurada del
gobierno por tratar de mitigar el
desabastecimiento y ese descontento que
hay en la sociedad o también responde a
una necesidad sistema de empezar a
renovarse de hacer cambios de hacer
reformas o modernización
sí bueno muchas gracias por invitarme al
programa un saludo para todos ustedes y
en el estudio para toda la audiencia que
tienen ustedes en todas partes y un
saludo también para la señorita paula
que nos acompaña en el día de hoy el
caso cubano es un caso muy singular y
bastante difícil de entender para
cualquier persona que él no haya vivido
en cuba durante muchos años y haya
sufrido diferente tipo de experiencia he
coincidido con la señorita paula de que
estamos en una etapa después de el
coronavirus occovi 19 como lo queramos
llamar que estamos un etapa a nivel
mundial de serios problemas económicos
de una inflación muy alta de muchas
situaciones que han dañado
prácticamente al mundo entero muy pocas
naciones han sido
afectadas pequeña mente todo han sido
con con un gran contenido de afectación
y en el caso cubano la afectación es
mucho más grande porque porque estamos
hablando de un país
desde
1959 hasta la fecha ha estado gobernado
por un solo partido por una sola familia
aunque hoy en día esté díaz canel como
presidente del gobierno cubano él
realmente quienes gobiernan en cuba son
los miembros de la familia castro raúl
castro- sus hijos y otros miembros más
de esa familia esta familia ha gobernado
a jugar con mano de hierro durante mucho
tiempo lo han hecho
con la ideología comunista pero un
comunismo a la latinoamericana al caribe
es decir a la cubana donde han estado
prácticamente manejando la economía de
diferente manera hacen dando de mantener
el poder teniendo una economía que se lo
permita ha sido un gran fracaso se
vieron obligados cuando se derrumbó el
bloque comunista encabezado por la
antigua unión soviética el principio de
la década 90 se vieron obligados a
aceitar la inversión extranjera en el
área de servicio en la cuestión de los
hoteles fundamentalmente porque estaban
en una crisis total y necesitaban
capitales necesitaban el dólar americano
para poder sobrevivir actualmente están
haciendo otro cambio similar a ese pero
ya raúl castro también cuando tomó el
poder después de la muerte de su hermano
e hizo otro cambio con cuestión de
facilitar la inversión extranjera y
otras cosas incluso aflojo onceno dentro
de cuba para que el cubano pudiera tener
algunos pequeños negocios seguirle es el
punto clave aquí si no funcionó para
nada la inversión extranjera y no
estamos en contra de que ellos
flexibilicen que permitan la inversión
extranjera en igualdad de condiciones
para todo el mundo pero también estamos
a favor de que le permitan al pueblo
cubano a ser dueño de su propio negocio
en la misma igualdad de condiciones que
cualquier extranjero escogido por el
gobierno cubano puede actualmente
invertir en cuba es de louis no podemos
entender que una nación si si lo a
cortar porque se me está extendiendo
mucho tengo muchos temas para abarcar el
tema el tema tiene muchas aristas
hay algo importante paulo se mencionaba
bueno luis enrique también lo recalcó y
es el contexto internacional la
recuperación económica mundial después
de los confinamientos que ha dejado la
pandemia de kobe 19 esto es transversal
para todos la inflación también es
transversal para la mayoría de los
países pero que se sabe de la situación
de cuba
en este momento para tener que tomar
este tipo de decisiones más allá del
contexto internacional al interior de
cuba cómo está la situación en términos
económicos
bueno por supuesto que yo estoy hablando
desde buenos aires y tal como decía luis
el respeto a los procesos internos de
los actores y de los protagonistas eso
se lo tendría que preguntar a un cubano
fundamentalmente pero si lo que quiero
remarcar es el proceso sostenido en el
tiempo que ha llevado adelante donde hay
un concepto que planteó louis que me
parece muy interesante este gesto del
socialismo a la cubana no y los rescató
porque creo que a diferencia de quizás
como hizo la unión soviética que también
mencionaba luís que
desarrolló condiciones para conformarse
como potencias por ejemplo industria
militar en el caso de cuba la prioridad
siempre fue el desarrollo de la
inversión en ciencia y en salud entonces
nos encontramos en una situación de
crisis como ya mencionamos anteriormente
por ejemplo cuba tuvo capacidad de dar
respuesta a su población con una vacuna
no sólo una sino dos pero son tres
vacunas que se desarrollaron en
territorio cubano
que me parece que eso marca la
diferencia con otros esquemas que hacen
que el socialismo a la cubana tenga la
particularidad de haber puesto al ser
humano como prioridad donde ya sabemos y
se estaba desde hace muchos años que es
un territorio libre de analfabetismo
donde no hay mortalidad infantil donde
como ya dije al desarrollo de ciencia y
tecnología la producción de vacuna
poniendo siempre como prioridad al ser
humano y bueno en este contexto por
supuesto que aparece la crisis atraviesa
la crisis y eso es parte del mismo
proceso democrático está viviendo en el
desarrollo propias contradicciones no
claro si es destacable ese papel que
tuvo cuba a lo largo de esta pandemia a
ver como usted dice paula como usted ha
mencionado haber desarrollado tres
vacunas contra el kobe 19 que incluso ha
logrado exportar a otros países y se
quedó en el
escenario o en el capítulo de tratar de
ganar una aprobación internacional por
parte de los organismos internacionales
para poder ser distribuida
mundial pero su vacuna le garantizo
también poder tener una alta tasa de
vacunación dentro de su población luiz
henrique entonces quiero terminar con
usted de armar este rompecabezas para
entender la situación interna del país
en términos económicos usted nos da un
panorama más o menos de la historia de
la del desarrollo económico que ha
tenido después de la caída de la unión
soviética este periodo especial que
significó un montón de cambios para el
país y mucha autoridad también pero en
este momento aparte de la coyuntura
internacional del cobi 19 cómo está la
situación interna
si tenía problema inicialmente que me
escuchaba con un eco y eso me permitía
ni concentrarme ni hablar muy bien ya en
estos momentos resolvieron ese problema
está muy bien me dio gracias
gracias por la pregunta quisiera
contestarle un par de cosas primero la
señorita paula mencionó que en cuba se
preocupan mucho por el cubano y por el
ser humano señores como podemos pensar y
ella vive en argentina imagino que
argentina como ella pudiera creer que el
argentino no tenga derecho a invertir y
tener su propio negocio en argentina y
yo como cubano si pudiera ir invertir
argentinas un americano un francés un
canadiense un japonés pudieran hacerlo
como ella puede pensar que el gobierno
de argentina si no le permite al
nacional tener su propio negocio y poder
incluso innovar crear de cubrir hasta
una vacuna como ella mencionó que
también voy a responder eso como podemos
decir que ese gobierno y poniendo el
ejemplo argentina donde ella vive es
prioriza su ciudadano yo creo que no yo
creo que esto es más que incoherente que
un gobierno que no le permite a los
nacionales tener lo mismo negocio en su
propia tierra que si le permite a los
extranjeros puede estar preocupado por
esos nacionales son totalmente falsos en
el caso de la vacuna señor en los
gobiernos comunistas en el mundo entero
siempre han hecho lo mismo la dictadura
cubana le comprueba china la vacuna la
fórmula de la vacuna no la inventó y han
hecho esto muchas veces y lo han hecho
en todos los países comunistas a través
de los tiempos la antigua unión
soviética le facilitaba a todos los
satélites europeos incluyendo a cuba
muchos de sus inventos para recordarle
algo en cuba había un televisor llamado
caribe que era el mismo televisor ve o
no me acuerdo el nombre del ruso
fabricado en la unión soviética nada más
cambiaba el nombre le cambiaban el
nombre y dos o tres adornos fuera cuando
usted abría ambos televisores ruso el
cubano en el mismo eso pasó con la
vacuna no nos dejemos engañar y aparte
muy ineficaz la vacuna muchos cubanos
que fueron vacunados luego se enfermaron
y muchos de ellos murieron es decir esto
es un fraude como toda buena propaganda
el comunismo y por desgracia mucha gente
buena en el mundo se la cree es
rápidamente porque sé que ya que ella
llevó algo de tiempo y lo que está
haciendo la dictadura en estos momentos
tratando de sobrevivir están tratando de
el dólar la moneda fuerte dólar o euro
para sobrevivir estamos hablando de una
nación que tiene tres monedas tiene el
dólar o el euro que prácticamente lo
mismo el tiempo que permiten uno al
tiempo que permiten otro pero lo mismo
tienen una moneda equivalente al dólar
al euro
llamada zeus y tienen otra llamada se un
p que es el peso cubano
el cubano gana su salario en peso cubano
y luego para comprar un poco de leche un
pan o una libra un kilogramo que como
venden en cuba de carne o pescado tiene
que comprar con los pesos cubanos que
ahora valen 125 pesos cubano un dólar
con un salario aproximadamente 30
dólares el cubano que lo que ganaría el
beso aproximadamente 30 dólares tiene
que comer comprando todos los productos
en dólar y con 30 horas no se compra ni
un kilogramo de pescado que tengo aquí
que les puedo mostrar hasta una imagen
de que cuesta 53 horas un kilogramo de
un tipo de pescado específico en una
tienda de dólar en cuba en pozo en
palabra el salario de un cubano no
alcanza para un kilogramo de pescado
entonces de que estamos hablando de que
ese gobierno se preocupa por su pueblo y
que la inversión es para eso cuando el
pueblo no puede con su salario ni
comercio pilar amor pescado en el mes
luis enrique para el aula le doy la
palabra sobre lo que está diciendo luis
enrique y yo me me lanzo a decir aquí
que los últimos años pues el estado
cubano en cierta forma descuidar la
producción nacional de algunos bienes
importantes de primera necesidad para
darle preferencia al importado que era
mucho más barato importar lo que hacerlo
ellos mismos y de esta forma recaudar
un poco más de divisas a través de el
turismo pero pero las exportaciones y
las importaciones han tenido un
desequilibrio muy grande a lo largo de
estos años su opinión sobre lo que acaba
de decir luis enrique y sobre esto que
básicamente es una industria que ellos
han dejado de lado y se han enfocado
solamente en la industria del turismo y
han dejado de lado algo básico
bueno por supuesto que
hay que no solamente cuba hay que
contextualizar esto hizo la revolución
sino que la hizo en una isla donde
lamentablemente la diversificación
de la matriz productiva queda muy
limitada por lo cual ya estructuralmente
los países quedan condicionados por sus
condiciones climáticas por por su
extensión por su por su riqueza
productiva pero no sólo eso porque es un
país rico en capacidad productiva sino
que además obviamente el bloqueo ha ido
generando la obsolescencia la
imposibilidad de importar lo que refiere
a insumos industriales y termina
sucediendo esto que pasa en muchos
países dependientes no solamente en cuba
que es la dependencia de las
importaciones que termina significando
relegar el desarrollo productivo
nacional el desarrollo de la industria
nacional que al final es lo que
garantiza la producción de puestos de
trabajo hoy en uno de los de los nudos
gordianos si se quiere de los países
dependientes bienes o agua también está
dentro de la división internacional del
trabajo dentro del sistema capitalista
que es el que impera a nivel mundial que
es el hegemónico a nivel mundial y
entonces por supuesto si aparecen estos
condicionamientos que van tratando de
sortear desde esta mirada que les decía
al principio claro no voy a poder pensar
en inversiones sustentables en
inversiones que no sean especulativas
pero que trabajan ayudando a resolver
estos estos problemas que son
estructurales y por el otro lado para
responderle al origen relacionado de
plantear que no se puede invertir en el
país y demás ya depende mi perspectiva
es social no miro desde la posibilidad
de los privados y particulares no de
llevar adelante
inversiones con el dinero que tengan
porque en general las personas que
tienen condiciones para invertir son muy
pocas y problemas también más me
preocupa son las grandes mayorías a los
problemas estructurales que generan la
desigualdad en general que el
capitalismo y por eso
en ese sentido es un ejemplo porque no
no no se ha podido terminar de desarmar
esta estructura donde lo social lo
colectivo lo comunitario y en un sistema
democrático que por supuesto es el que
se ha podido mantener a ras del proceso
electoral en año año
se ha seguido sostenible para mí eso es
el gran ejemplo es la gran fortaleza y
es lo que hace que cubano sea un museo
sino que siga siendo un ejemplo de cómo
planificar la economía poniendo a las
personas a ser humanas como quería
paula continuó con usted para
preguntarle en este orden de ideas y de
acuerdo está este llamado que hace el
gobierno cubano a diferentes empresas y
gobiernos para que inviertan en el país
en estos dos sectores minorista y
mayorista
pues hay muchas muchas empresas y grupos
económicos interesados precisamente
porque el mundo ya está muy conectado
muy globalizado encuentra uno
prácticamente todas las marcas en los
diferentes rincones del planeta pero el
hecho que el estado
controle absolutamente todo no le quita
atractivo para esta inversión no será
como una especie de de
espejismo de venderles un mercado que sí
es muy atractivo pero que a la hora y en
la práctica no va a ser tan productivo
ni tan beneficioso para las empresas que
finalmente entran es porque ven un
potencial para ganar dinero
sí por supuesto las empresas nunca
quieren el control ni las regulaciones
del estado es la misma decisión si lo
trabajado argentina está sucediendo lo
mismo en donde hay gobiernos
progresistas gobiernos que que llevan
adelante sus políticas de gobierno con
fuerte intervención estatal los privados
tienden a buscar la deslocalización los
lugares nuestros min haciendo más barato
y la regulación estatal que lo que
garantiza mejores condiciones para los
que viven en el territorio nacional
entonces me parece que en este sentido
aparece la cuestión de oportunidad que
evidentemente hay capitales que están
interesados a invertir y no veo porque
no puede haber una regulación estatal
donde se pueda garantizar como lo que
entra se distribuye que es lo que al fin
y al cabo termina siendo la discusión
fundamental la distribución de la
riqueza
luis enrique y desde su perspectiva
quienes pueden
responder a este llamado qué tipo de
empresas o qué tipo de empresarios o de
gobiernos se muestran interesados en
entrar en cuba- partiendo de la idea que
usted dice que esto es simplemente una
maniobra del gobierno para mantenerse en
el poder y para mantener este sistema
vigente
bueno muchas sabemos que las grandes
empresas siempre tratan de ganar capital
donde pueden incubar un mercado virgen
prácticamente o en cuba no hay nada cuba
prácticamente todo está por hacer en más
de seis décadas de comunismo las
carreteras en cuba no sirven el campo
está totalmente abandonado para ganado
de una planta con espina llamada marabú
popularmente en cuba y así está toda
cuba está totalmente destruida incluso
las casas las todas las construcciones
quitando los hoteles y todo el sector de
turismo en cuba casi todo está destruido
y todo hay que reconstruirlo todo hay
que crearlo no hay una cadena de tienda
independiente libre todas son del
gobierno por cierto la inversión
extranjera a todo el que vaya invertir a
cuba- debemos aclarar algo para quien
vea y no conozca todo esto siempre se
hasta 50 por ciento el 50 por ciento de
la ganancia para la empresa extranjera
que invierte en cuba y 50 por ciento
para el gobierno cubano el gobierno
cubano lo hace a través de algunas
empresas y les puedo poner el ejemplo de
ello como por ejemplo héroes de girón es
decir algo de propaganda comunista es
una empresa que tenían ellos en cubas
unos años con la cual fusionaron
una compañía creada por el más marambio
quiero poner este ejemplo para que mucha
gente entienda incluyendo paula que no
lo entiende joel más marambio un chileno
él carrillero amigo de fidel castro su
padrino oficial de la fia el castro
estudió en cuba cerrado en cuba agente
de inteligencia especializado en cuba
vivió muchos años en cuba luego estoy
hablando cuando la dictadura de pinochet
en chile
estuvo exiliado en cuba todo ese tiempo
luego cuando la democracia volvió a
chile regresó ya como empresario y como
productor cinematográfico todo esto
preparado en cuba es decir con la
ideología del comunismo fue para cuba en
los años 90 invirtió terminó en el 2001
creando una compañía en cuba llamada rio
zaza y sea en coordinación con héroes de
girón una empresa cubana del gobierno
mitad de ganancia para cada cual esto
producía aproximadamente 100 billones de
dólares al año es decir 50 millones para
cada uno 50 millones para el gobierno
comunista y 50 millones para más mar abi
su hermano marcel bueno en el año 2010
aparece muerto el gerente chileno de
ríos asa en la habana una muerte
bastante oscura luego dijeron la
autopsia cubana que había muerto de un
problema de salud sabemos los que
conocemos el comunismo que fue asesinado
este hombre muere le quitan la empresa
mas marambio lo acusan y en el 2011 lo
condenan a 20 años ausencia mas marambio
no pueden más nunca cuba un hombre que
era ahijado político de fidel castro que
fue parte de la inteligencia castrista
que difundió el comunismo en américa
latina y se invirtió con lo castró un
amigo de ellos le ayudaron su compañía
la asesinaron a su gerente y perdió toda
su inversión en cuba ese es el riesgo
que se corre cualquier empresa
extranjera de la que buscan sacar dinero
fácil cuando van a invertir en un país
donde no hay leyes que garanticen la
permanencia de su compañía y la
estabilidad y que el gobierno cuando le
venga en gana no se le quite hay otra
cosa en cuba la ley se viola y se
pisotea cuando le vienen gana la
dictadura y vuelta de enrique en una
nación que los nacionales no tienen
derecho a invertir a tener pequeños
negocios le contesto a paula no hay
necesidad de que un cubano tenga 100
millones dólar para invertirlo mas
marambio con 2 millones comenzó su
negocio de ríos hace un año los
provisiones y en el año y no solamente
eso no solamente eso rápido termino no
solamente eso
mientras los nacionales de un país no
tienen derecho a invertir a tener su
pequeño negocio creado de la nada y que
poco a poco va creciendo y se convierte
en negocio millonario o que convierta en
garantía para eso tampoco lo hay para
ningún extranjero claro y hay que decir
que las empresas extranjeras que se han
mostrado interesadas en entrar a
invertir en cuba en este nuevo capítulo
de inversión extranjera han pedido
garantías muchas garantías es la gran
pregunta que hacen los diferentes
conglomerados las garantías legislativas
que puede dar el gobierno sobre cómo
pueden invertir allí luis enrique
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa pero por favor respóndeme muy
puntual porque ya está entrando en la
parte final del programa y se van a
crear muchos temas por fuera el ejemplo
de china y vietnam países comunistas que
han logrado tener unas economías
abiertas a la inversión extranjera y
bueno ya todos conocemos el éxito a
nivel comercial que es china el gran
exportador a nivel internacional y
también en vietnam como ha surgido en
términos económicos después de la
apertura de su economía
cuba podría estar en capacidad de
repetir algo similar a lo que está
viviendo por ejemplo vietnam
china porque el tamaño de la economía
china es gigantesco pero a tener una
economía abierta que genere ingresos
para el partido en el poder que le
permita hacer inversiones contundentes
para sus habitantes o usted cree que
cubano tiene el músculo para eso bueno
lo primero es que esta inversión
extranjera que están abriendo en cuba no
tiene nada que ver a la china ni a la
venda mitad en china en ventana y
multimillonarios nacionales y la empresa
hay empresa privada china ya la empresa
privada vietnamita en cuba no es así y
lo segundo es que en cuba los recursos
naturales se sobran que también le
contestó un poco a paula sobre eso en
cuba por ejemplo hay unos los mejores
mangos de todo el continente americano y
no lo comemos eeuu en otras partes del
mundo porque el campesino cubano el
gobierno no le permite exportar los
cosas así entonces ellos están
simplemente tratando sobrevivir como lo
hicieron el año 93 con la primera
inversión extranjera con los hoteles
como luego abrió un poco más raúl castro
cuando tomó el poder de parte del
hermano
y con díaz canel a la cabeza
oficialmente aunque seguimos en arco lo
castró están tratando de buscar
desesperadamente de donde agarrarse
porque la economía cubana es un colapso
total cuba se está cayendo a pedazos y
ellos lo saben y emprende la economía
nacional y permitirle al cubano tener
libre empresa que el cubano pueda
emprender pueda liberar el potencial que
tiene el pueblo cubano que cuando llega
otra nación enseguida progresa o no se
lo permite ni quieren inversiones y
seguirá con dólar efectivo ya vamos a
hablar del estado y el futuro que va a
tener la economía cubana ya se lo va a
preguntar luis enrique paso a
preguntarle a paula por el contexto
internacional a nivel empresarial vemos
un auge de las startups en diferentes
rincones del planeta el emprendimiento
como una de las grandes apuestas de los
gobiernos para que los ciudadanos puedan
crear empresas fácilmente
con bajos costos y con algunos subsidios
o ayudas dependiendo del país del que
estamos hablando vemos también la
necesidad de estar interconectados no le
parece usted que cuba está completamente
ajena a esa coyuntura internacional en
donde el emprendimiento está a la orden
del día el desarrollo tecnológico está a
la orden del día las start-up se están
ganando le terreno a muchas
multinacionales en diferentes sectores y
cuba- simplemente se quedó paralizada en
el tiempo apostándole a una medicina que
si es reconocida a nivel internacional a
unos sectores muy puntuales pero
completamente fuera del contexto mundial
no le parece
yo creo en primer lugar
el concepto de emprendedurismo es un
concepto que también merece debate que
podríamos conversar largamente porque
bueno evidentemente estas personas que
estén bailando que se construyen desde
la prensa hegemónica desde distintos
lugares que pretenden mostrar al
emprendedor como un empresario exitoso
me parece que no es congruente con lo
que sucede en realidad en relación a los
verdaderos niveles de concentración
a quien verdaderamente se apropia de la
riqueza que se produce en el mundo
entonces le es casi que crear una
ilusión de que el emprendedor va a poder
generar riqueza cuando en realidad entra
dentro de una estructura que ya está
planificada en términos de la
apropiación privada de la producción
social entonces ahí hay hay un tema
fundamental y por otro lado también
viéndolo desde este proceso de
concentración que hablamos todo lo que
es tendido de fibra óptica las
inversiones en industria aerospacial en
satélites para garantizarla
precisamente requiere de enormes
inversiones prefieren de enorme
decisión por parte de los empresarios de
ir a cubrir ese territorio y
evidentemente el otro día escuchaba el
programa de maría fernanda barreto que
hablaba también hasta mismo en este
programa y planteaba de como el bloqueo
y el embargo genera condicionamientos
para garantizar ese acceso a la
información que también es un derecho
humano y que evidentemente aparece
dentro de la lista de
acciones que las medidas miers y
coercitivas unilaterales
ammán generando y van perjudicando el
término incluso de violación a los
derechos humanos porque la comunicación
hoy es un servicio universalizado que
los cubanos a cubanas no pueden acceder
no tienen que ver precisamente con la
decisión política de gobierno sino con
las grandes empresas monopólicas que son
las que las que llevan adelante las
grandes inversiones
no vemos por ejemplo al gobierno
desconectar el sistema de internet a la
hora de llevarse a cabo las
manifestaciones ciudadanos por ejemplo
en las de la habana no hay servicio
internet en el momento en que se están
dando estas manifestaciones ciudadanas y
también dificulta el acceso a internet
justamente para evitar que los
ciudadanos puedan organizarse a través
de redes sociales para organizar estas
manifestaciones el gobierno cubano quita
y pone el internet o la electricidad
también vemos los apagones a los que
están sometidos en la habana la capital
apagones de muchas horas denegándoles el
acceso a la electricidad que les impide
tener aparatos médicos conectados o sus
electrodomésticos conectados comida que
se pierden los refrigeradores
simplemente porque el gobierno no
dispone de recursos para poder
garantizar eso a los ciudadanos no
necesariamente es de una política que
venga desde el exterior luiz henrique
llegamos a la parte final del gol del
programa
conclusiones de lo que puede seguir
entonces para este país muy puntual por
favor porque me quedan pocos minutos y
también paula tiene derecho a hacer su
conclusión del programa entonces le pido
que sea muy puntual
con lo que sigue entonces para este país
en términos de inversión en términos de
economía el desarrollo rápidamente
bueno veremos a mucha gente invertir
próximamente tratando de aprovechar la
desventaja del cubano que no puede tener
su propio negocio y la desventaja de
muchas otras personas de otros países
que tampoco el gobierno cubano sólo va a
permitir a estas personas estudiadas y
escogidas pero aparte de eso es cierto
me queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa paula su conclusión que sigue
entonces para cuban en materia de
inversión bueno creo que lo que sigue es
seguir buscando la manera de
diversificar la matriz productiva de
poder exportar bienes y servicios lo
mismo que cualquier país un país más
dentro del mundo con la diferencia de
que va buscando la manera de encontrarle
la vuelta para que todos siga haciendo
dentro de un modelo sustentable con las
personas con movilidad tal como le dije
anteriormente pues ya veremos cómo se
desarrolla entonces este capítulo de
inversión luisenrique paula les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros a ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía sigan con france24
[Música]